my father who moved our family down from
Chicago to Dallas Texas when I was about
six weeks old for an opportunity in
computers he started working in system
software in the early 80s and then from
there I watched his career evolved from
system software to application software
to the Internet then finally to security
software and then about two weeks after
he retired in the mid-2000s I'd already
graduated from college his company was
acquired by IBM so IBM was really this
presence in his career life and also our
personal lives where it was always
nipping at the heels of what everyone
else was doing in Texas and I think as
many writers in Los Angeles kind of
looking to do our net expect Chris and I
met when we were working together in
social media Disney and we're kind of
getting increasingly interested in the
role of Technology in our lives you know
whether it pushes us farther apart how
it brings us together and we thought
kind of the genesis of that story was
1983 and the rise of the personal
computer and we saw an opportunity in
what was happening with reverse
engineering of the IBM PC they kind of
tell people the story they didn't know
so anytime you can kind of find that as
a dramatist
you know that's a pleasure for us well
we talked so much about Silicon Valley
and Silicon Alley and we talked about
silicon beach but you're focused on
silicon Prairie tell us about what was
happening at that time silicon Prairie
really deals with that swath of area
between Dallas and Houston and Austin
and compact was the first company to
reverse engineer the IBM PC and they
were out of Texas Michael Dell was
building computers in his dorm room at
the time we also had Texas Instruments
which everyone is familiar with the
Speak & Spell there's their speech
synthesis and speech synthesis ation
technology and also their calculators
they were in the personal computer
industry industry and you had people
like Charles Tandy who was a leather
maker at first but then acquired
RadioShack and started building his own
IBM compatible machine that he sold on
the market
I think Texas was also really appealing
dramatically because we could play it as
kind of be under the line where people
who had washed out of these other
traditional tech hubs whether it be New
York or Silicon Valley kind of came for
their second chance their last chance
and in a lot of ways you know that
that's always what you're looking for
people seeking redemption to do right
where they've failed in the past and it
gave us the opportunity to do kind of a
modern Western I mean in recent years
there have been so many tech themed
stories movies about Mark Zuckerberg and
Steve Jobs now a show about modern-day
Silicon Valley called Silicon Valley how
do you think the themes in all of that
material compared to the themes that
you're exploring in your show I think
that the themes are very similar across
the board because it's really about
humanity's relationship with technology
and when Chris and I first came up with
this idea we wanted to tell a story of
how do we get to where we are now
there's no going back technology is
completely interwoven into our lives and
what does that mean what does that
symbiosis look like and as we look back
through history personal computing
really seemed like a watershed moment
where we could explore that relationship
and the flavors different from another
show or another movie but the parable
seems to be always the same which is
humanity creates the technology the
technology is a reflection of humanity
in all of its imperfections yeah and I
think we're becoming increasingly aware
in our modern age to the effect that the
individuals who made these things put
their personal imprint into the machine
you know I think we see the great
creativity of Steve Jobs and the Apple
products and I think the social network
and movies like that show you how maybe
Mark Zuckerberg put some of you know his
his demons in his brilliance into the
into the Facebook product so in that
same way we wanted to capture the way
that that our heroes at our fictional
company Cardiff electric baked their
problems into the machine they're
building
even in 1983 so it sounds like you've
you've gotten some approval from people
who were in the business at that time
you have been showing your your program
to the modern-day players in Silicon
Valley some of the feedback that I've
heard from people who have seen it is
they are impressed is that feedback from
the people who are currently the
influencers in the world of technology
is that important to you is it important
to the potential success of the show I
think so I mean I really love that
people are responding to it in that way
people who are working in technology now
people who are not as familiar with the
history of how we got here are looking
at it and feeling like it's plausible
feeling like it's real and that way they
can appreciate the drama and enjoy the
story that much more in the metal
component tree you know in the hand work
itself has changed but but the dilemma
is on a human level people face are the
same you know KITT can you have
work/life balance you know can you
iterate something fast enough to to get
it on the market before something else
completely eclipses a you know a maya
visionary am i fraud the challenges on a
personal level
are kind of timeless and I think we're
finding that modern audiences can still
connect